seriously uh
mate that's nice that's broken look
that guy's like the cream of me boy
we're recently at the uh Sinead O'Connor
janaza is that correct correct Teddy
obviously you're famously Catholic
Muslims are lovely people Muslims are
very tender and very loving people
despite what anyone may think you know
so a lovely reaction British or when you
become a Muslim you join what's called
Omar the family so you referred to as
brother or sister or Auntie you know and
you talk about the Prejudice that you
had yes um you know experience that oh
yeah but but it doesn't it makes me
laugh you know it actually makes me
laugh and in a strange way it makes me
proud I can't really explain why but if
somebody hates me because I'm a Muslim I
kind of like stand up a bit taller
actually all of the write-ups that I
found none of them mentioned Islam uh
when she passed away
[Music]
and you can see it really touched him
even even Bono was was incredible you
know you could see that uh it just
really touched our hearts you know the
recitation of the Quran alhamdulillah a
very good friend of mine brother Eddie
from the dean show who I've known for a
number of years from the very beginning
when he started it I was among his early
guests and masha'allah our brother Eddie
has been very active in promoting dawa
spreading The Message of Islam and he
has now taken everything to the next
level Eddie has now after a number of
years on The Dean show taken the tower
efforts to the next level which is that
of establishing a tower center for the
USA he is about to launch it in its
fullness but it has already started in
Florida and he needs your support this
is an effort which began already some
months back and they need your support
for spreading The Message of Islam in
the USA so my brothers and sisters reach
out to support him we need your support
now
assalamualaikum greetings of peace my
next guest 30 year 36 year old Irish
born and bred Tony
was recently at the Sinead O'Connor
janaza private funeral prayer and he's
here with us to tell us more
about his experience how he ended up
there and his journey also to the way of
life that Sinead O'Connor
accepted here with us Tony
[Applause]
and his final messages
[Music]
how are you
doing Tony
very well very well thank God all good
all good so you were recently at the uh
Sinead O'Connor
janaza is that correct correct Teddy
correct absolutely yeah were you a good
friend of her families or because this
is a private this is a very uh private
uh event and how did you end up there
well uh I'll tell you I'll tell you this
story at the uh basically uh I was um at
home I have never met Sinead or her
family other than of course she's a
being a sister in faith you know since
2018 and I've been of course a fan of
her since growing up you know such a
rebel such a wonderful soul and she
contributed so much to you know our
society here and um lots of things so
look I was at home uh prayed morning
prayer and I was sitting there and I
came across a video on your on your
channel and uh I made a few calls and I
spoke to uh
Umar Kadri who was actually leading the
the janaza prayer and he invited me and
requested that I would join them
um for the for the prayers on the day so
I took the journey from my hometown and
went there and it was all Allah's plan
you know and it was such a privilege and
an honor to meet her family and uh to be
there which of course was a very sad
occasion but um you know it was uh it
was a great privilege and honor and
something very beautiful
so alhamdulillah she actually had the
proper Islamic gymnastics
wash the body and to prepare it for the
prayer everything
led the prayers and it was it was really
beautiful and uh her family are just
such beautiful people you know and not
surprising you know I mean she was a
really a great sister a great lady and
uh they were just so welcoming and
wonderful and it was just an unexpected
honor like personally for myself uh I
was I was quite honored and uh it came
out of nowhere you know God works in
mysterious ways and I I had no
expectations at all of being there but
uh it just uh last minute it came true
and as I said a really great honor
so this is nothing you planned uh ahead
of time nothing it's just happened you
actually saw one of the the reporting
that we did because we got some news
from someone else that possibly this was
not going to happen and they were
writing about it in the paper correct
and then we reported up we reported on
it to hopefully create some awareness
and so this actually ended up happening
and you saw the program we did and you
you you drove what almost uh two and a
half three hours down to the was it in
Dublin yeah it was near Dublin the um
the janaza prayer was in Bray which is
quite near to Dublin like it's so funny
uh how it happened because as you say
those are pretty much the circumstance
and it was just uh when I saw the video
that was on your channel I just uh and
and uh you were there speaking with the
sister and you know you you made a call
that if anyone in Ireland any Muslims
you know over there that something could
be done and obviously that would be a
great worrying concern I mean we're all
going to to die and uh that's the thing
and as Muslims of course we we we hope
and pray that uh when we do die it'll be
in a good way and that we'll receive the
proper send off appropriate to uh
to you know our faith and uh it was
something that just my heart I was
sitting there I was like wow I have to
do something and I had no idea what to
do to be honest and I was thinking of
different strategies you know like that
you're gone what can I do and and I have
no power really to do anything you know
just a simple man and I said wow and uh
I saw the picture of Sinead uh with the
sheikhandry when she took her shahada
and entered into the Islamic faith back
in 2018 and I thought okay if anyone
should know what's happening so it
should be uh the Imam you know so I
contacted him I found his phone number
online I'd never spoken to him before
actually believe it or not our paths
hadn't crossed
um and uh just made the call and we
spoke and he put my mind at rest that
look I he had contacted the family and
that the family were very open and
welcoming and that they were happy for
the janaza uh to take place and the
prayers to be done there was no no issue
and like for me it was funny because I I
noticed like uh when our sister passed
away that like obvious see there was a
lot of coverage he's a someone who's uh
you know worldwide uh with her music and
of course with her um accepting Islam a
few years ago she's you know amazing
notoriety but uh here she's like
completely a household name you know so
there was a lot of write-ups in the
paper when she passed and I noticed
actually that for example they had
pictures of our sister in her hijab and
things but all of the write-ups that I
found none of them mentioned Islam uh
when she passed away I I was
specifically looking for it and it was
almost written out of the narrative and
that's fine I understand that and uh but
as you said the day I think the day
before your video on your channel guys
um there was a big write-up in the paper
saying that Sinead would receive no
Muslim funeral and uh a lot of all these
things you you saw that one also I think
the Irish Irish examiner for example a
big Irish paper was literally the
headline and as I said even in
retrospect now I look back what is the
headline read again I want to miss quote
but I think I think it was
um Sinead will not receive a Muslim
funeral that was pretty much the
headline so again that was you know that
was the kind of um the vibe around the
time as you say the day before or the
the burial and that concerned me of
course even watching your video but
alhamdulillah in the end uh it was
actually completely different what
happened as we know now even from the
media coverage you know the has been
clear that uh she received Islamic
prayers and that everything was done you
know alhamdulillah
you know so yeah so you did you get a
chance to meet some of her family which
uh family members were there yeah I
heard like there was there was family
members there's maybe 25 30 members of
our family all beautiful people and uh I
met her father had an opportunity to
talk to her dad you know you met her
father also Sinead O'Connor's father
what a gentleman what an absolutely
lovely man I mean you could just tell
straight you know he's just a beautiful
a beautiful man and one of the
statements we were speaking after and
one of the statements he made to me was
you know tears in his eyes and he just
he just said to me he said Sinead was a
True Believer she was he repeated this
phrase and it just you know it stayed in
my heart out what a gentleman even when
we were at the we were at the burial
ground
he was very keen for for us to pray
beside the grave everything it was it
was you know he took the lead in that he
was you couldn't you couldn't really
find more welcoming family to be honest
and more respectful and you know even
talking to other members of the family
like I chatted to Bono chatted to Sir
Bob they were there
um who was that again sir Bob Geldof the
you know the Boomtown Rats front man
from the 80s band you know well-known
singer and Bono from YouTube
these are these are like some uh famous
some musicians absolutely at the time
and they would have grown up actually
not only would they have been musicians
at Chinese time they would have been
actually they would have grown up Bob
sir Bob was explaining to me afterwards
we tried it briefly and he was saying
that they actually they all grew up in
pretty much the same area which is you
know subhanallah remarkable that they
all kind of had the same trajectory in
becoming kind of worldwide Stars so uh
and even sir Bob made the comment he
taught me he said uh the Islam prayers
he said they were so hurtful heartfelt
was the phrase excuse me heartfelt and
you could see it really touched him even
even Bono was was incredible you know
you could see that uh it just really
touched our hearts you know the
recitation of the Quran alhamdulillah
and uh that came across even from the
family afterwards it really uh even
there was a man working in the graveyard
and he just walked over to us and said
your prayers were so so beautiful it was
to be honest it was a remarkable
experience I met her nephews I met uh
cousin's heart they were just uh you
couldn't really have felt more welcome
um it was it was incredible it was
actually incredible you know
much respect goes out to the family of
Sinead O'Connor absolutely you know for
for honoring this and allowing this to
to go ahead and take place absolutely
yeah yeah much much response much love
and respect yeah yeah as I said you you
just couldn't have met you couldn't have
met kind or more welcoming people really
it was it was uh it was touching you
know it was a very emotional uh
experience and uh one that will I think
stick with me for inshallah a very long
time you know it was yeah if anybody
else out there can get us in touch with
I don't know if you um at a chance or
anything uh we'd like to talk with
Sinead O'Connor's father you know these
statements are sticking with me you know
uh to see someone like that at the end
you know she was a Believer he said and
hopefully we can go ahead he can see
this and he can consider absolutely now
he consider what she had considered and
you also what you not just considered at
one point you actually went from being
an inspiring hip-hop artist is that yeah
yeah that was that was my that was my
life before before Islam yeah absolutely
I I I I reship up artists like uh what's
that back in the day what were the and
these guys also accepted Islam it was uh
House of pan house yeah yeah which is
actually a great a great name for this
Dunya in a sense you know
what are they're from from Ireland now
Irish background Irish background jump
up jump up and get down that's it
absolutely yeah Jump Around jump around
I think jump up to that says yeah that's
damn yeah so that's a very well known
hit him yeah but but is it true they
also accepted it I'm not aware of that
but you know if they did I heard that
yeah so tell tell us shortly uh to shift
over a little bit to your story your
journey what happened that you also went
from considering at one point to
actually accepting Islam from being
inspiring hip-hop artists you know to
you know where you're at today here on
the dean yeah absolutely look at uh I
grew up uh you know in uh my adaptive
family here in Ireland we're uh born and
raised Catholics pretty much everyone
that's the system you know there's uh
and we grew up in that uh Catholic
School uh Catholic Ireland and uh you
know I would have gone to church and all
that even in my teens like I always had
a kind of a definitely had a spiritual
side I was always interested I I did
believe in God you know and uh for sure
and then when my teens came I actually
um transferred over in a sense to like a
Pentecostal Church there was a Nigerian
church here in town I had a lot of
friends from Nigeria and from Nigeria
and other Nigerian friends that moved
here and immigrated we have a big
immigrant immigrant population here so I
was attending uh a Pentecostal Church
Evangelist Church that's more a church
that you know different style than
Catholic you get to read the Bible more
it's more involved longer services so I
enjoyed that for a few years and then at
my late teens early 20s I just post I
was uh you know gone to church on Sunday
but of course most of Saturday night was
in the club so I I guess I made an
informed decision that instead of being
a hypocrite I have to drop one of these
activities so I think I dropped the
church activity you know and uh which is
funny when I look back at it but uh yeah
there was a few years in the wilderness
like I said I would have always still
believed in a higher power a Creator and
then in my early 20s just said wondered
really true life and you know different
thing things would be in your heart a
lot of pain like we talked about pain
already house of pain but it's of course
what this life is there's a lot of tests
a lot of Trials and challenges and I
suppose I was struggling with them if
I'm being honest you know what I mean
and uh you know what it is with drink
and with going out to pubs and clubs I
mean everyone in in the world probably
knows Irish people for a few things
which is having the crack having the
laugh and having the the few points you
know whether it's Guinness or whatever
it is and that was very much the culture
but that's okay if you're you know for
some people but it certainly wasn't for
me and uh I ended up in a bit of trouble
in my mid-20s like um one particular
event and I ended up spending a night up
in a jail cell and I do remember that
night just uh kind of reflecting inward
you know there was a lot of you can
blame other people you can play but that
night just the loneliness and being in
that cell and I just reflected and I
says
is this it like is this what you came
into this life or there was this very
clear question and within my heart and
the answer was no I knew inside the
answer was no that there's something
more than this this isn't this can't be
it
um and after I went out and I was
waiting for the court to come and all of
that and I felt it was actually innocent
you know uh it wasn't a thing where I'd
done some something major I felt like I
was hired done by but I still knew that
the problem was being caused by
something within myself there was
something that I needed to change
and uh around that time I'd be a guy
again like the Irish happy go lucky most
people ask you how are you getting none
and uh you just say I'm fine you know
I'm Grand and you wouldn't open up too
much but one particular day I I was
visiting um walking through town and I
visited uh an aunt of one of my best
friends uh a Nigerian sister and I
always know that she'd be praying in the
shop or she'd go she'd close the shop
and go for prayers
um she'd have the Quran playing in the
background so I knew her to be like a a
kind of a spiritual lady and someone
that I could talk to and even I used to
go to her house when I was young she'd
look after me she knew me well and uh
that day oh how are you brother and uh I
remember just saying no I'm I'm not
really okay I remember opening up and I
told her look I have a few problems and
stress and all of this and uh she just
kind of explained life to me in a quick
way she gave me hope number one she told
me look everything's fine Brother this
is a human experience but she laid it
out from an Islamic point of view God
created us we're here we're being tested
we have an enemy enemy is the shaytan is
the devil and you're continuously going
to be tested in life and she explained
to me like that uh how important Faith
was
and she gave me some little prayers she
wrote them down she wrote down something
she said when you go to your house
I had no chance to remembering it so I
was like okay can you write these down
so she wrote them down phonetically in
English things like that how to seek
Refuge from shaytan when you feel
stressed just little things but I can
say it a feeling I had when she was
talking was like
I can't explain it like my heart being
like a jigsaw puzzle with one piece
missing and it felt like she was just
after putting reaching in and putting in
that peace or that that piece clipped
within my heart that oh this is
something very important so I remember I
asked her for a Quran I was like okay I
straight away I was like I want to Quran
mid-20s at this stage like I said and of
course I knew Muslims I had friends who
are Muslims I used to say salaam to them
I used to say things like inshallah you
know God willing I had respect for
Muslims always since I was young even
during the whole like uh 2001 the early
2000s when there was a lot of propaganda
and stuff I kind of even as a young
fellow I saw through it it never really
affected me and I I did really like uh
Islam and Muslims but from the outside
you know and I remember even hearing the
call to prayer I had a CD somebody gave
me when I was young and the call to
prayer was on it and I loved it it was
just something I I had no issue with but
never wanted or had the sense to enter
inside fully or to investigate gate
further or read the Quran or anything
like that but from that day when she
spoke I was like wow I really really
want to read the Quran so she said look
I'll ask my husband to get you one and
so a few weeks passed and I kept calling
I used to go to the local Halal shop and
ask them please can someone get me a
Quran and they'd say yeah brother we'll
be going to the mosque because Ennis is
a small town we have a small as I said a
migrant population and there would have
been a little prayer room in an
apartment at that time no mustard uh and
it so things would have been a bit like
low-key in terms of like uh Islam being
being you know predominant or available
around her as I said no Islamic Center
in the town so I waited a few weeks and
the feeling never left uh the feeling
never left to to read the Quran so I
kind of got tired of waiting I suppose
after a few weeks and I went on Google I
Googled okay Islamic Center Ireland
Limerick so in the neighboring City in
Limerick there's an Islamic Center so I
asked my friend at the time wasn't
driving and I asked my friend look can
you drop me to Limerick I I really
wanted go and get a Quran I just have a
feeling I need to read it and uh I took
the journey down around 30 40 minutes
and we got there knocked on the door
um Imam Khalid who's now a good friend
of mine you know a very nice brother he
came out and uh greeted me and I asked
him I said look I want to I want to read
the Quran is it possible you can give me
a Quran that I can read
and uh he said I'll see what I can do
and he went inside he came out gave me a
beautiful green covered Quran handed it
to me and I thanked him and said look
hopefully I'll see you again please God
take care sat back in the car and uh I
said again inshallah I'll never forget
it I sat down I opened up the book
a holy book and I second chapter which
is also strained because I was watching
about uh Sinead story sister sinead's
story and she was saying that the second
chapter was what she read uh when she
became Muslim or when she knew in her
heart that Islam was the Fate for her
and I just opened the book and started
reading the second chapter of the Quran
and first maybe nine verses and uh just
tears it was like just Tears start to
flowing out of my eyes and that wasn't
me now I now I'll cry at the drop of a
hat you know I'll cry whether I'm
praying or it's in my heart's changed so
much but at that time I wouldn't have
been crying and uh I knew there was
something to it and I couldn't stop the
tears flowing out and I could see my
friend beside me he was also reading it
and my friend is actually far more
intelligent than I am he's a smarter guy
he's but he wasn't having the same
reaction so again that told me that it
was something more than the words it
wasn't just oh beautiful poetry you know
again being a poet being a a rapper
being someone who writes lyrics I could
tell the difference between being moved
by the words and being moved by
something else at the the level of the
heart shall we say and uh from that
moment I made a made a decision I think
in my heart that I was gonna pursue this
and I went home I started learning how
to pray and at this time of course I'm
still waiting for the court to happen
for the issue that I have so the the
sister who had uh you know explained me
things the Nigerian sister she also gave
me a little booklet with some prayers so
I went to the court date and again I was
learning to pray at home and the first
thing I did when I learned it was to ask
forgiveness I felt like a lot of you
know things inside and regret about what
I'd done in the past and you know how
I've been living and stuff so that was a
kind of a big breakthrough for me and uh
that was the first time I prayed on my
knees or made sir Jude bowed my head on
the ground to to Allah and that was
again profound and I felt like I would
say a new person still going through
issues in life you know still you know
struggling but I I could feel things
were changing and I remember being in
the court and uh it was so mashallah it
was amazing I I was reading some prayers
and uh one of the prayers in particular
said that uh
asking Allah for help and uh basically
saying that uh asking Allah to tie the
tongue of your enemies you know for for
your enemies when they're not speaking
the truth for them for their tongues to
be tied and I could see in the court and
as as I said I felt I was innocent I
truly did I felt that I was hired done
by and I could see as I was reading the
prayer and the my own solicitor was
talking and the judge was talking and I
could see things were going on and they
weren't making sense to be honest things
she was saying on my side were things
that just weren't making sense but it
was all going my way and I remember
showing it to my friend beside me and
saying look look at the prayer I'm
reading and look what's happening and I
remember my friend who's a non-muslim
and he just said keep praying keep
praying so alhamdulillah the truth came
out and even the judge he said look this
is a good guy this was a
misunderstanding on the event and I
don't want to hear about this anymore
just let this man go back about his life
this was just uh it doesn't require any
attention it's fine and I was I mean
this was a miracle and again I walked
out of the Court tears in my eyes and
just you know so moved by it and that
was the beginning Eddie of my I suppose
my journey into Islam
your uh wife also she's Irish my wife is
French my wife is French
her dad is from the Congo and her mom is
from the Caribbean and she's born in
France yeah
and she also accepted his name yeah in
uh 2017 a few years after me she she
also accepted Islam and well
alhamdulillah
I want to get your reaction to something
because we started off talking about
Sinead O'Connor and this this reality
that should really motivate every human
being to seek out what the true purpose
of life is where we're going when we die
and there's another individual who's
very famous out there you've heard of
him uh Conor McGregor
absolutely Connor well Irish my Irish
brother absolutely yeah
I want to show you this uh clip and uh
get your reaction to it because it
revolves again around this topic of
death powered off a blade boy
all good mate all good I'm totally don't
worry about it seriously all right
that's nice that's broken look
because of the cream of me boy
yeah
Jesus Christ
after getting away my life there boys
yeah you want it you want to no I don't
give him a box my all good all good save
flowers God bless you
sorry
you want me to bring the bike home and
all that you know what yeah
oh
good look
of a whip
I'm here what's your name
[Music]
with his car you have the big in the
back wasn't it for him Nick that's all
God blessing
but still here thank God
that's all that matters so it's
interesting uh obviously he's thanking
God and he realized that he could have
died he had
expressed also um that he he could have
he could have died this could have been
it for him and all that money he's
accumulated all of the start of and
everything at the end it doesn't matter
so what advice if uh Conor McGregor he
gets a chance to watch another Irishman
such as yourself
uh also the daughter they say of Ireland
of the Irish people Sinead O'Connor
she also accepted Islam what advice
would you get for Connor to uh trigger
something in him to pick up the Quran
like you did you were so
full of passion you were going to the
mosque you were asking for it you opened
up the second chapter of the Quran just
like Sinead O'Connor did sincerely
wanted to know the truth the purpose of
life
and here you are with us here on the D
show as one who submitted his will to
the creator of the heavens and earth for
Muslim in Islam what would you say to um
Conor McGregor because death is a
reality can come at any time absolutely
and look first of all Conor is a legend
and and he really is and what he's done
for even putting Ireland on the map and
given a lot of young people confidence
in this country and another thing I've
noticed about Conor he always mentions
God I've seen him in nearly every
interview because I do follow his
trajectory I follow his career and he's
done great things and um he's a strong
man and uh he he knows what he's about
in himself and he knows more about faith
and death because as you know what
martial arts and stuff you step into
that ring and you're facing debt every
time but we've seen it with people like
art and Cena Michael Schumacher look at
Michael Schumacher how he's how his life
turned he's dice with debt every week
then retired from formula one which is
the most dangerous business you can
really go into and then he has an
accident on a skiing holiday and that's
that's how fine our life is like Conor
face and death all the time and then
your life nearly ends on a you know a
trivial a biking accident and that's how
I mean even me that's I I think about
death all the time in a sense because it
could happen anytime and we need to
really we do need to think about what
what's my purpose what am I doing here I
can't bring the money with me I can't do
anything and of course it's not uh
forbidden to live a good life it's not
forbidden to earn money to be rich
dessert these are these are all okay
things but there is fundamentally of
course that other level and where our
relationship with the one who created us
is the most important and we will go
back to meet our maker as we say in
Ireland we you'll be meeting your maker
one day and that's what Islam is simply
all about the God he's thanking is the
exact same God that I'm thinking like
when you become a Muslim you don't
change and then you're you're you know
worshiping the moon or it's it's God
it's the one God who created you and
that's who it is and I I'm no one to
advise him to be honest but what I would
say to him is I anyone is just
investigate and search for The Troop
with an open heart and uh read the Quran
to anyone read listen to the Quran and
just have an open heart to Islam because
it's it's a perfect way of life the
people who practice it are far from
perfect and a lot of us will ever be
perfect but itself what it gives and I
could sit down every day and show like
uh how Allah Works how God works in my
own life and it's incredible it blows me
away and there's times where we all go
through ups and downs that's the human
Journey it's not like a person accepts
Islam and suddenly becomes a perfect
person
and uh I'm I'm tired from that and I
feel like even with uh you know with
Sinead Allah has given an example the
kind of people that Allah wants to to be
considered as Muslims and to come into
the faith are not perfect people or the
people who seem to have it all together
with the people like I was I was broken
and I can't speak for anyone else my
life was all over the place and Allah
chose me out of the people around at
that time to guide me and uh that's
changed my life in incredible ways and I
can only imagine how amazing it would
and how happy everyone would be if Conor
was a Muslim it's not I've often thought
about it's something I've prayed about
and as Muslims we believe that if if God
Wills you to pray everything you do is
is without the will of God it wouldn't
be happening so when when I pray that
prayer I often reflect after and think
wow Allah wants me to make this prayer
so I I pray and I do hope that one day
Connor will Embrace Islam inshallah and
uh you know I think he's a very good man
and I admire the fact that he's a
Believer and as I said he's always
respect to Believers that's you know I
think the khabib thing Society gets
misrepresented he probably gets a lot of
hate from the Muslim Community but that
was in the context of a Moment In Time
the fight game and all of that stuff you
know if you think about Umar the one of
the greatest sahaba that we have he was
on his way to to kill the prophet peace
be upon him that was his intention that
day when he left he went to kill the
prophet and then by the time he got
there he was a Muslim you know and and
this is this is the thing so nobody's
far away nobody's outside of God's mercy
and love so I would just encourage
anyone who's interested in Islam just do
your own thing and open up the Quran ask
God to guide you from your heart and uh
inshallah God will guide you as as he
guides absolutely you know
and uh as you uh had mentioned um that
Ireland is also suffering
um many massive mental health issues
addiction High suicide rates it's
affected Ireland in a big way and this
is Islam is the solution to all of these
ills that are affecting Society so
you're a Living Testament of that how
your life has changed
and also so many millions around the
world who are coming to Islam
are getting to experience that firsthand
so we extend the invitation to Conor
McGregor and anybody else out there
we'll send you a free copy of the Quran
go to the dean show.com we'll get you
one you don't have to drive here and
drive there just uh go ahead and visit
us and we'll get you a free copy sent to
you thank you very much yeah thank you
very much for sharing that uh story of
your experience at the Sinead O'Connor
janaza and very elated and happy to um
hear your story
benefits so many uh people around the
world yeah that's true just finally I
would definitely say that that's true in
Ireland we have that issue at the moment
as I said it was a Catholic country and
due to you know Sister Sinead spoke
about it previously with you with so
many scandals with the church and
everything people have backed back from
their faith but the people I believe in
their heart all of us know when we truly
reflect that uh there is a maker we
didn't just come here from nothing and
this world this life is painful it is a
test and we're planning all short time
could finish now could be maybe 70 years
80 years 100 we can't take anything with
us except for what's in our heart our
good deeds and we all want to go to
heaven no one wants to die we will but
we all want to go to heaven we want to
have peace whatever our version of peace
is and that's what Islam allows you to
reflect daily upon that and work towards
that and that gives you hope Allah says
don't Despair and kill each other or
kill yourselves and uh yes those
problems you mentioned are prevalent
here and Islam brings a peace in the
heart Allah says don't despair of my
mercy and uh that just that can keep you
going through the darkest of times you
know and uh I think uh you know it would
be it would be very good you know for
for people to reflect on that and find
that spiritual connection and I do truly
believe Islam finds that as you say
we've seen that even with brother Andrew
Tate many people around the world who
are embracing this way of life our
brother Kevin Lee recently you know so
many people so
thank you for sharing that brother thank
you Eddie brother
foreign
Center up open and running in sha Allah
imagine every person that prays here
gets educated and guided to Islam here
you'll get a part of all those blessings
and rewards insha Allah what are you
waiting for brothers and sisters you're
going to leave it all behind anyway so
go ahead and invest in your Hereafter
that's Everlasting click the link below
donate right now may God Almighty Allah
reward all of you
[Music]
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedineshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you